the kansas city chiefs
had a linebacker's coach britt reed who
is the son of head coach andy reid his
contract expired after the season he was
not kept around one of the reasons
presumably he wasn't kept around is
because of the incident that occurred
the thursday night before the super bowl
brit reed now charged with dwi class d
felony facing a prison sentence of one
to seven years according to 41 action
news in kansas city how about this
.113 blood alcohol concentration that is
0.033 above the 0.08 legal limit in
every state now
and analysis concluded that reed was
driving 83.9 miles per hour i hope that
wasn't the speed at the time of impact
of the vehicle that was parked my
goodness but uh
a horrific situation we've talked from
time to time about the five-year-old
girl who was horribly injured and will
have permanent injuries according to the
reports that are out there but brit reed
facing
prison and uh his coaching career may be
permanently on hold and there are still
unanswered questions about where
he was drinking
at a time when the pandemic limits the
options to go out to a bar or a
restaurant and when you're
at work the week of the super bowl
practice meetings in your office at the
facility
what did the chiefs know and when did
they know it i think that's going to be
a question that ultimately is explored
not by the criminal
process but by the civil process when an
effort is made on behalf of the
people who were injured in this accident
to find compensation for the medical
bills that will be significant that
already are and will continue to be if
there are permanent injuries you look
anywhere you can for somebody who may be
legitimately responsible and if there's
an argument to be made that the chiefs
knew or should have known
that that brit reed was engaged in these
activities and he went and got on the
car you know it's tougher than the
typical dram shop case when you prove
that you served someone who shouldn't
have been served but if there's a legal
theory to be articulated and if there's
reason to say that the chiefs knew or
should have known what was going on
shireen that may be a path that this
eventually takes in the effort to find
compensation for the expenses that will
arise as a result of this of this
incident that was sparked by brit reed
and such a tragic story mike and i think
another lesson to everyone don't drink
and drive in this day and age of uber
and lyft and everything else there is no
and there never was a reason to do it
but far less reason now with all the
share rides available that that you can
get so easily so it's just another
lesson don't do it and and don't do it
multiple times either i mean that's
another thing here you know if you if
you've done it once and made a mistake
and got away with not hurting anybody or
killing anyone
don't do it again i mean just just don't
don't drink and drive that's the lesson
one of the most significant changes in
our society over the last 40 years has
been the dramatically increased
sensitivity to the issue of drunk
driving the fact that the people who do
it are made into pariahs as they should
be and nowadays
this thing we carry around that there
are so many bad things about one of the
good things is you press a button and a
car shows up and if you're too
inebriated to press a button and have a
car show up then you definitely
shouldn't leave where you are especially
not with your car keys it's that simple
i remember there was a time 10 years ago
or so pre uber pre-lift pre-ride sharing
apps where
the nfl and nfl pa had a system
available where i'd do was call it and
players were reluctant because they
thought the information was going to go
back to the teams nowadays you do it all
on your own it's no big deal it's 10 15
bucks it's you get home and you are safe
and more importantly no one else is in
danger because you're behind the wheel
of a two thousand three thousand pound
steel machine that can wreak all sorts
of havoc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports